el cyborg es un sujeto real es un ser
humano real que tiene prótesis o que
tiene elementos mecánicos o electrónicos
en su cuerpo puede ser porque la persona
tenga problemas de salud y las necesite
o simplemente porque desee obtener la
inmortalidad tener un mayor poder
cognitivo o tener un mayor poder en su
cuerpo
la importancia de la corporalidad es
esencial dentro de esto porque se habla
del cuerpo fragmentado de ese cuerpo
roto detrás del cual podemos ver varios
movimientos sociales yo investigue la
fundación sálvora la asociación atrás
humanista mundial también el instituto
de la inmortalidad
la asociación 2045 la asociación mormona
atrás humanista y el movimiento de sar
el encuentro que detrás de estos
movimientos sociales que trabajan los
derechos de los iphones la salud de los
ibooks la democracia salvo hay muchos
monopolios económicos del poder estos
monopolios económicos plantean
fortalecer las cirugías las drogas
farmacéuticas o cualquier otro tipo de
droga es el techno bio poder
esto es algo muy delicado que debe ser
investigado porque si nosotros podemos
investigarlo nos vamos a dar cuenta de
todo lo que hay detrás a nivel político
cultural y económico mi apuesta es por
la pedagogía interpretativa la pedagogía
que yo trabajo es una pedagogía que
equilibra la estética que es realmente
la sensibilidad más que el arte la
lúdica que tiene que ver mucho más allá
del juego es la relación entre el
impulso sensible y el impulso formal
como él decía schiller del sujeto y
también el mito la lúdica la historia en
nuestro cuerpo está en nuestra historia
debemos recuperar ese cuerpo hacer
investigaciones en las escuelas hacer
más investigación y hacer un
reconocimiento de lo que está sucediendo
con la fragmentación de la corporalidad
sino con todo este tipo de realidades
que se están dando a través de muchos
movimientos políticos y económicos que
están detrás de la ideología así que
muchas gracias